I'm going to show you how I make my
super easy 10 minute lazy wonton noodle
soup starting with three cups of broth
this is pork broth but you can do veggie
broth chicken broth a mix of them or
even water if you want but I do
recommend broth I'm gonna go boil some
noodles on the side this is flour
noodles but use whatever you like okay
soup is boiling I'm gonna add in some
bok choy and then some store-bought
wontons these are pork and shrimp but
you can pick your favorite flavor I'm
doing eight pieces now we're just gonna
let this cook for like five minutes
until the wontons are fully cooked looks
like it's all done we're gonna turn off
the heat now you just Ladle over your
soup add in bok choy finally add in your
wontons I'm doing some white pepper and
a little bit of chili oil for my wontons
I like to smother it in this soy sauce
black vinegar sauce
hmm
it's just so good it's so simple so easy
to make it's light Yet full of flavor
and it still feels indulgent and it's
super easy to customize you can add your
own veggies protein whatever